estábamos adelantando que El Salvador
puso a disposición de Haití y otros
países lo que es su experiencia con el
plan de seguridad control territorial
esto puede ayudar a Haití es trasladable
la respuesta del Salvador a un país con
las particularidades de Haití
entiendo que sí entiendo que primero eso
refuerza la cooperación sur y es
importante que Haití pueda aprender de
la experiencia exitosa hasta ahora a
pesar de alguna críticas de los grupos
de Derechos Humanos Pero nadie puede
negar que a la política en esta materia
seguida por el presidente álvaroño ha
sido exitosa y son
miles de miembros de gangas o bandas
armadas en El Salvador que están
actualmente preso o en proceso
judiciales pero todavía no ha habido
reacción a nivel oficial no hay reacción
desde la cancillería haitiana o desde la
sede gubernamental la prima tuyo he
visto la la jornada de ayer lo que se
vivió en Haití y porque aunque
entendemos y sabemos que la vida del
primer no corre peligro en los momentos
que estamos hablando pero nadie sabe de
su paradero esto pues ha provocado un
cambio en su agenda porque hoy tenía
previsto
Instalar los miembros del alto consejo
de transición que él había designado
hace hace un par de semanas y que por
varias varias razones no había podido
instalar entonces hay que esperar una
una toma de posición oficial del
gobierno respecto a la propuesta
salvadoreña hacia ese punto a mi
pregunta hablaba usted de Ariela y
grupos Defensores derechos humanos
serían caminos 78 uniformados perdieron
la vida desde que llegó al poder en 2021
que cambió en el país desde la Asunción
de ahí como Primer Ministro hay
realmente inacción por parte del
gobierno como dice Muchos oficiales que
se manifiestan
hay muchas críticas y efectivamente a
una falta de voluntad a nivel
institucional hemos tenido episodios tan
dramáticos como los últimos que se han
visto
seis cuerpos expuestos en en la
carretera después de haber sido matado
por bandidos Y eso nos recuerda el
episodio de los miembros de la unidad
que también cayeron en una trampa
tendida por los gangueros de la zona de
pueblecito de Dios pero no hay hasta
ahora la disposición la voluntad de
parte del alto Comando de la policía y
de de parte también ya del Primer
Ministro o del gobierno central en
enfrentar de manera convincente a los a
las bandas que controlan buena parte del
territorio de la capital Puerto Príncipe
Y esto ha provocado una indignación una
indignación
legítima que la población civil haitiana
también entiende y apoya no queda poco
tiempo pero no quiero dejar de hacerle
la siguiente pregunta no la violencia
propagada por bandas criminales
atraviesa por supuesto Haití como
venimos describiendo pero no es la única
crisis que vive este país caribeño que
otros frentes críticos debe gestionar el
gobierno haitiano
definitivamente hago una falta de
Liderazgo y por tal razón
el grupo Montana a través de un acuerdo
en un acuerdo que fue firmado por más de
mil representantes de la sociedad o de
la nación haitiana pues Proponen un
cambio cambio profundo a nivel de la
dirección del Estado hoy día el estado
haitiano está manejado por un solo
hombre porque los demás poderes del
Estado son inexistentes o inoperantes y
la el acuerdo este esta propuesta pues
un cambio que será a tener una gestión
bicéfala con un presidente y un Primer
Ministro en vez de tener a un solo
hombre con una concentración de poder